we all strive to be healthier versions
of ourselves and improve our overall
well-being
most of the time we tend to concentrate
only on the body focusing on our
physical health such as exercising daily
and eating a well-balanced diet while
this is extremely important it is not
the only component of total well-being
that we should be improving
your mind is equally just as important
and we need to nurture our mental health
the mind-body connection is the link
between a person's thoughts attitudes
and behaviors and their physical health
the mind and the body are not two
separate entities although they are
often treated that way your physical
health and emotional health are
intertwined in what's known as the
mind-body connection
how you think can affect how you feel
and how you feel can affect how you
think hence that's why we often hear the
saying your thoughts become your reality
have you ever felt your stomach tighten
up when you were anxious or have you
experienced high levels of stress at
work which caused you to have trouble
sleeping well
that's you experiencing the mind and
body connection
it is important to note that the mind
does not mean the brain
the mind consists of mental states such
as the thoughts beliefs attitudes and
emotions whereas think of our brain as
the hardware that allows us to
experience these mental states our
mental states can be fully conscious or
subconscious we can have emotional
reactions to situations without being
aware of why we are reacting a certain
way and each mental state has a
physiology associated with it whether
it's positive or negative response felt
in the physical body for instance
constant worry and stress over our jobs
finances or family issues can cause your
body to react as if it is under attack
your body releases hormones that speed
up your heart rate and breathing
increases blood pressure and make your
muscles tense this physical reaction is
called the fight of flight stress
response if you're constantly feeling
this way this can lead to high blood
pressure as well as other mental issues
which can cause depression or anxiety
on the other hand what we do with our
physical body such as what we eat and
how much we exercise can also impact our
mental state if you live an inactive
life and eat crappy food you will
constantly lack an energy struggle to
focus and feel moody however if you eat
a well-balanced diet and exercise on a
regular basis your body will produce
endorphins making you feel good and
boost your energy levels as well as your
positive attitude a healthy body keeps
you well and active and a healthy mind
keeps you focused and engaged hence to
achieve total wellness it's not one or
the other but it's about bringing
balance and harmony to the mind and body
do you sometimes feel lifeless or bored
do you dread each coming day and feel
like you're merely existing instead of
really living you feel like you're not
making progress and time flies really
quickly well
stop living life on autopilot making
unconscious automatic decisions that
don't align with how you want to work
and live the single most important step
is to become more aware of our mental
states to increase the consciousness in
our thoughts attitudes beliefs and
physical actions or reactions
once you're aware of what you want
you can align your thoughts and actions
so here are four simple steps to
increase the mind and body connection
have you seen the movie inside out the
film is so brilliant in depicting our
emotions visually sometimes it's so hard
for us to express or visualize how we
think and feel so a fun way is to look
at our emotions as those characters
portrayed in the movie when we imagine a
situation the primal parts of the brain
react as if it was really happening
therefore positive visualization can
help you control or manage your emotions
so ask yourself these questions what am
i thinking and feeling think of the
characters in the movie how is that
affecting my physical body am i tensed
up is my heart rate increasing rapidly
how can i change that and negative
thoughts or emotions to a more positive
one and bring about balance to my mind
and body
by asking yourself these questions
you're bringing awareness to your
thoughts and attitude hence you're able
to take control of your mind and change
the outcome to a more positive one
sometimes we talk to ourselves self-talk
is your internet dialogue it is
influenced by your subconscious mind and
it reveals your thoughts beliefs and
ideas self-talk can be both negative and
positive
positive self-talk is an inner monologue
that makes you feel really good about
yourself and boosts your self-esteem it
is an optimistic voice in your head that
encourages you to look at the bright
side pick yourself up when you fall and
this can enhance your performance
the world's greatest athletes might not
always be the strongest physically or
the most skillful however they are
mentally strong and they often have a
positive inner monologue with themselves
what they tell themselves right before
the competition can determine the
outcome
if you believe your self-talk is often
too negative
let's learn to shift that inner
monologue here are some examples
i'm overweight and so out of shape i
might as well not bother and stop trying
well i'm capable and strong and i want
to get healthier for me i've never done
this before and i'm pretty sure i'm
gonna fail at it this is a wonderful
opportunity for me to learn from others
and grow farming new habits take time
and effort but if you start to become
aware of your inner monologue positive
self-talk can become your norm so here
are some tips i've been practicing to
build up a more positive self-talk
give yourself positive affirmations
seeing positive words or inspiring
images can be enough to redirect your
thoughts this can be as simple as having
positive affirmations in your home or
office or on your phone well basically
anywhere you spend a significant amount
of time
don't take yourself so seriously so what
if you mess up when we take ourselves
too seriously we believe that everything
revolves around us that's why we fear
being ridiculed and this stops us from
trying when you learn to loosen up on
yourself you open up space for play and
exploration and for change
surround yourself with positive people
whether you notice it or not we absorb
the energy and emotions of people around
us this includes both negative and
positive so choose to surround yourself
with positive people who encourages you
we all know that we should be looking
after our bodies eat well and move more
that's because how well your body feels
can also have an impact on your mind i
exercise regularly and eat a
well-balanced diet because i love how it
makes me feel i'm energetic throughout
the day i'm able to sleep better i feel
more relaxed and have a more positive
outlook in my life for me i love to lift
weights and perform heat exercises when
i workout i'm in my own zone where i'm
really in tune with my own body and with
what i want to accomplish and this helps
me to build a stronger mindset as well
so don't just exercise mindlessly be in
the moment be in tune with your own body
and this can help you to push further
especially when you feel like giving up
there are many other forms of exercise
that you can also incorporate which
focuses on the mind and body connection
such as yoga tai chi qi gong and pilates
when it comes to food we often hear this
saying you are what you eat
there's actually a lot of truth in that
food is fuel food fills your brain and
body and the fuel you choose will
directly affect the structure and
function of your body and brain this
doesn't have to be complicated stick
with the basics fill your body with high
quality real foods that nourishes the
brain reduce on processed foods and
refined sugars because over time
consuming too much junk can cause
inflammation in the body mood disorders
as well as other mental and body
illnesses
relationships are one of the most
important aspects of our lives yet we
often forget just how crucial our
connections with other people are for
our physical and mental well-being
people who are more socially connected
to their family friends and community
are happier physically healthier and
live longer with fewer mental health
problems compared to those who are
isolated or less connected having close
positive relationships can give us a
sense of purpose and belonging it's not
just how many friends you have but it's
the quality of your relationships that
matters how we interact and form
relationships has changed so much over
the past decade nowadays we're so hooked
up on social media and the online world
that we have often forgotten what it
feels like to have a meaningful
relationship with someone you might have
lots of friends online but if you are in
need for emotional support
do you really have someone that you can
call and turn to
here are three things you can do to
start building positive relationships
invest your time yep
you need to consciously put time aside
to connect with your family and friends
that means don't work long hours or even
the weekends
be present yes you're physically with
your family and friends however do you
catch yourself engaging on your phone
instead of engaging with them
you don't always have to be online
because those online friends aren't real
relationships be present connect and
spend time talking and doing things with
your family and friends
recognize unhealthy relationships
living in conflict or within a toxic
relationship is more damaging than being
alone and this can negatively affect our
mental and physical health so
recognizing this can help us to get out
of it move forward and find solutions to
issues while we still have a lot to
learn about the mind and body connection
there is no doubt that taking care of
our mental health is just as important
as our physical health the mind-body
connection isn't just about how the mind
affects the body it is also about how
the body affects the mind hence making
healthy lifestyle choices is an
important part of maintaining the
balance between mind and body i hope
that this video has taught you to be
more aware of your mind your thoughts
because it will also affect your
physical health if you enjoyed this
video do give this video a thumbs up let
me know in the comments below and do
also hit the subscribe button if you
haven't yet done it okay so remember to
continue to stay active eat a
well-balanced diet and let's look after
our mental health as well all the best